- [Kelly] Well, this series
finale of "Supergirl"
is in a few weeks,
So did you keep anything from the show?
I mean, by that did you steal anything?
- I did! (laughs) I took a few things,
but no; there for some reason.
The props department I think found
like a tub of Dinosaur figurine somewhere,
and they'd just put them
in the random places
of the Catco Office set.
- Wait, what? (laughs)
- I don't know.( laughs)
So I would see them,
and I had this, weird love
of dinosaurs as a child.
- [Kelly] Oh!
- We all love dinosaurs
as kids. - [ Kelly] Yes.
- But my love of Dinosaurs lasted-
- I love them,
as adults in movies
that his daughter is in
" Jurassic World".
[Ron & Clint] Yes, yes. - Me too
Actually, Jurassic park was
a huge reason I loved them.
But I wanted to be a - Because
it's an amazing franchise.
- Yes, yes
- But I want it to be a paleontologist.
- Oh, you were in it?
- Yeah, I was in it. - Oh!
- [ Melissa] Until my parents
took us to dinosaur Ridge in Colorado,
which is a live dig and
I saw, how boring it was.
(crowd laughs) (clapping)
- Paleontologist, everywhere
were like "W-H-A-T-E-V-E-R".
(laughs)
- [Kelly] It's so interesting!
But have you guys ever take
anything from like a set
that you've worked on?
- I have a cocoon from the movie "Cocoon".
- [Kelly] Oh my God! - Oh
my God. (crowd clapping)
- I didn't want to bring it up.
- He just won, won all of it.
- I didn't want to bring
it up. Cause I was like,
I didn't know if that
was like, you're like,
since you been gone,
and everybody only thinks I have one song.
But like look, "Cocoon"
all your films I love.
But "Cocoon", changed my life as a child.
I loved Cocoon. - well-
- It's one of my favorite.
-[Melissa] Me too.
- And I, and I also have
a little mermaid tail,
for the little baby mermaid. From-
which I donated to the
Academy's new museum.
- [Kelly] Oh ! That's cool.
- So you can see this little
mermaid tail from splash.
- Oh my God. - Oh! So
you are like robin hood.
You like stole, and gave to
someone. (laughs) Okay, okay.
You didn't keep it for
yourself, that's cool though,
Cocoon, that's a good one.
Did you take anything from set?
- Oh yeah! - [Kelly] Yeah (laughs)
- I'm the he-he-man. (kelly laughs)
Ron bust me one time,
because I did bring a
screwdriver to the set,
the last day of the "Grinch".
And they said no no no,
put the screwdriver away.
I do have "Whoville money".
- [Kelly] Yes! - yes. - [ Melissa] Wow.
- Okay, That's just as
cool as cocoon there.
That's pretty good. Okay,
That's nice. I'm just going
to go to sets and steal stuff.
(laughs)
- I don't have anything cool.
I should've sold them something
for American idol, but well,
you've, you've written your
first book, so congratulations.
That's so cool. - Thank you.
- [Kelly] And, and you
work with your sister?
- Yes, my older sister.
- [Kelly] Yeah, is she a writer?
Or do you both love writing?
- She, from as long as I can remember,
was always filling those spiral
memo notebooks that you get
for school, - [ Kelly] Oh!
like cover to cover with stories.
- [Kelly] I am your sister. - Were you?
- I have a spiral
notebook, I still like say,
"I'm going for school
supplies for my children,
and it's really me". Yeah.
- [Melissa] It's just satisfying.
- Yes. - [Melissa] Yes. - Yes
- So she would fill those cover to cover,
And so she was always writing,
she's written forever. And
- [Kelly] That's so cool.
- we kind of had this
idea that we wanted to
bring something that we would have loved,
reading when we were kids
out into the world. - Yeah!
- Something magical. We both
love fantasy as children.
- Me too, still as a
39 year old. - Me too.
- [Kelly] Yes, I love it.
Well, what is Haven secret about?
- It's about. Two twin sisters
who have magical powers.
That kind of relate to
the natural world. And-
- [Kelly] Here's my thing.
One sister is siding
the other one (laughs).
So exactly, what's happening?
(laughs) What's happening?
- I meaning,
would it be a sisterhood,
without some side eye, I feel.
- Cause like, cause y'all
have different powers, right?
- Yes. They have two
different powers that kind of:
one can communicate with animals,
and the other is more
elemental, Her powers.
It's really fun. The way
they interact, and story is
- [Kelly] I love it. -
really magical. Well, yeah.
- And just thank you, because
I love reading with my kids,
but I love now.
They're actually letting
me do chapter books,
and like even bigger ones.
So I love it. Every night we read-
- [Melissa] Oh! This is gonna be perfect.
- I know, I love reading, since
they like - I'm So excited.
- [Kelly] They'll get into,
but I love as well. - Yeah.
- Cause, I'm a child at heart.